For decades upon decades, conspiracy theories
have long captured the minds of many individuals
and groups across the world.
The infamous ones will always spring to mind
the moment somebody so much as speaks the
phrase “conspiracy theory” aloud; the
words alone conjure up questions like “were
the moon landings really faked?”, “did
aliens really have a hand in building the
pyramids?”, and “is there really a shadowy,
ancient order called the Illuminati controlling
the events of the world around us?”
Of course, the answer to all of these questions
is often a plain and resounding “no, now
please leave me alone”, but delving into
the world of conspiracy theories, collecting
and connecting evidence can be an interesting
exercise in imagination when it’s all done
in good fun.
But there is often a dangerous side to conspiracy
theories as well, and we don’t mean getting
so close to the truth that the men in black
show up at your front door and haul you away
to Area 51.
No, it’s important to remember the harm
that some conspiracy theories can do.
It’s an unfortunate truth that a number
of conspiracy theories, especially those more
prevalent in recent years, are often used
to unjustly villainize particular religious
or ethnic minorities.
Positing about ancient aliens can be fun when
you remember that conspiracy theories have
no actual bearing on the real world, but the
line has to be drawn somewhere; the minute
a ‘theory’ starts to delve into unseemly
territory, it’s best to realize that there’s
very little truth to it.
There is one infamous conspiracy theory, not
a vindictive or harmful one, that has stood
the test of time for almost as long as the
moon landings or Area 51.
Who really killed President John F Kennedy?
We all know, or think we know what really
happened on November 22, 1963, on that fateful
day in Dallas Texas.
But what if that’s the point, we all think
we know, but each of us thinks differently?
Grab your red string and shiniest tinfoil
hats and take a seat, folks.
Welcome to SCP-001, otherwise known by the
appropriate nickname, The Conspiracy.
Now, first things first,
some important information.
Anyone familiar with the SCP Foundation will
tell you that there are multiple entities
and objects referred to as SCP-001.
Everyone has some idea which of these they
think is the real one.
But, just in case you happen to be new here,
we’ll clarify for you.
The designation “SCP-001” doesn’t refer
to a single creature, object, or entity within
the Foundation’s archive.
Instead, it’s a collection of various anomalies
that have been encountered
and - mostly - contained
by the SCP Foundation.
As for why these various files are all collected
under this shared designation?
Well, that’s a conspiracy theory all in
itself.
It could be that these anomalies are some
of the earliest ever contained by the Foundation,
and were first encountered before they had
established the numbering system that they
currently use.
However, could these multiple SCP-001s be
an intentional misdirection?
Smells like another conspiracy to us...
Among the anomalies sharing the title of SCP-001
is the Gate Guardian, a powerful being believed
to be an angel standing at the entrance to
the Garden of Eden.
Then there’s the infamous Scarlet King,
another anomalous eldritch creature with similar
levels of destructive power, who is intent
on one day causing the destruction of all
creation.
Also known as SCP-001 is a Database containing
all of the proof the Foundation’s top brass
have collected that proves their entire universe
is the fictional creation of the SCP Wiki
authors.
Pretty wild stuff.
And then, there’s this SCP-001, the Conspiracy
itself.
As we mentioned before, it’s connected to
the assassination of United States President
John F Kennedy; very closely connected, at
least for a few seconds before it came out
the other side, that is, because in this instance,
SCP-001 is the bullet that killed JFK.
Now, history tells us that on Friday, November
22, 1969, the 35th President of the United
States John Fitzgerald Kennedy, was riding
in an open-top car as part of a presidential
motorcade traveling through Dealey Plaza,
in Dallas, Texas.
A former US Marine named Lee Harvey Oswald
opened fire on the President through the window
of a nearby building, tragically killing JFK.
But, ever since Kennedy’s death, there has
been rampant speculation about what really
happened in Dallas.
Most theories suggest that there was a secret
organization involved or multiple shooters
in addition to Lee Harvey Oswald.
According to the Foundation, through some
anomalous means, the shot that killed John
F Kennedy was fired by multiple unidentified
assailants, acting as part of the same - or
numerous - conspiracies, all shooting at the
exact same moment.
The events surrounding the bullet’s trajectory
are designated under the
codename Incident-001-Gamma.
Anyone alive that has memories
linked to Incident-001-Gamma
is part of the last population on Planet Earth
that can agree on a shared concept of truth.
They know what is true, thanks to all sharing
an experience of either hearing about the
Kennedy Assassination, or witnessing it in
person or on television.
When SCP-001 was fired, it
created Incident-001-Gamma,
which was both a pivotal moment in history
and also had a lasting effect on everything
that followed.
It might not be obvious how just yet, but
we’ll get to the repercussions in a moment.
The fact that multiple generations alive at
the time of Incident-001-Gamma have a consistent
memory of it, establishes a baseline.
Essentially, because these people have vivid
memories of the assassination, they also have
a societal memory of everything that had occurred
in human history up until that day in 1969.
The evolution of mankind, the various wars
that occurred had all been documented and
were held to be true.
There was a shared, collective truth among
Earth’s entire population,
up until Incident-001-Gamma
occurred.
However, reality had shattered in some way,
the moment that SCP-001 was shot towards JFK.
The sheer number of conspiracy theories that
tumbled out of the Kennedy Assassination weren’t
just rampant speculation.
Not only did everyone on Earth now have a
memory of what happened, they had their own
version of what they believed they had remembered.
For example, from the moment
that Incident-001-Gamma
took place and JFK was shot, there were already
conflicting witness testimonies from people
who were actually present in Dallas and saw
it all happen.
A significant percentage of eyewitnesses reported
some variation of seeing a strange, unidentified
figure referred to only as ‘Badge Man’.
Whoever he was, even if he was just a result
of civilians being unfamiliar with seeing
Secret Service agents, not everyone that was
present at Incident-001-Gamma can agree if
Badge Man was even there at all.
The only two people that
were definitely participants
in the assassination were President Kennedy
and Lee Harvey Oswald.
History diverged for everyone from this point
on, remembering everything that came before,
but having conflicting
memories of Incident-001-Gamma
and everything that followed it.
What the SCP Foundation knows for a fact,
is that Lee Harvey Oswald fired three shots
from his vantage point on the sixth floor
of the Texas Schoolbook Depository.
The first missed, the second delivered a wound
to the President as well as Texas Governor
John Connally who was riding in the same car
as JFK.
The third and final shot was SCP-001, which
vaporized the cranial cavity, killing him
and causing Incident-001-Gamma.
From that moment on, there now existed a confusing
and contradictory number of different perspectives
on the world’s history, all conflicting
with one another.
People’s perceptions began to divert away
from reality over the course of the next decade,
slowly and unnoticeably at first.
Everyone could still agree on what had happened
since Incident-001-Gamma for the most part,
until September 5th, 1975,
the failed assassination
of Gerald Ford, the 38th President of the
US.
Multiple witnesses reported seeing different
versions of the event, some even certain that
President Ford was, in fact, killed.
This even resulted in another attempt on Ford’s
life only two weeks later by a woman who believed
the President was already dead, attempting
to make reality align with what she thought
to be real.
But it gets worse, President Ford had equally
been affected by SCP-001, believing that the
Soviet Union had withdrawn from Eastern Europe
during the Nixon administration.
In reality, this didn’t occur until the
late 1980s.
That is the true effect of SCP-001, the disparity
between what someone perceives to be real
and what is actually real.
It can often manifest in frustration, we’ve
all once felt that we have the skills required
when applying for a job, only to have a rejection
email sent back to us.
Some of us believe ourselves
to be kind, good-hearted
people, yet can’t seem to find any friends
that would agree.
Living in a huge house can make a person feel
cramped and claustrophobic despite all the
space around them.
You can feel that there is something wrong
in situations like this, but you can’t explain
it.
This effect of SCP-001 can often result in
conditions like Imposter Syndrome, where someone
has the belief that all of their achievements
and successes are nothing more than a sham,
and that the best parts of their lives are
destined to fall apart because that person
does not deserve them.
That feeling of not belonging, the world not
aligning with what you think is true, all
comes from SCP-001.
The phenomenon known as the “Mandela Effect”
is also seemingly derived from the fractalization
that occurred after Incident-001-Gamma.
The Mandela Effect usually refers to a memory
held by an individual, or group of individuals,
that they believe to be true, but actually
differs from fact.
For example, the effect is named after Nelson
Mandela, who died in 2013.
However, countless people distinctly remember
news that Mandela had died in prison during
the 80s.
Misremembering history comes as a result of
a person’s perception and their living memory
being out of sync with that which is true.
Often, trying to undo the effects of SCP-001
can be more harmful to a person as having
their perception vary so dramatically from
reality.
Say you believed that all the Beatles were
still alive, you were positive of it and it
had always been that way all your life.
Then, somebody presented
you with actual historical
proof that John Lennon was killed outside
his hotel in the year 1980.
All the photographs, news reports, and other
evidence in the world couldn’t convince
you that what you thought to be true, in fact,
wasn’t.
Frequently, this leads to frustration and
confusion that could, and often does, damage
relationships with friends and family, causing
isolation and disconnection
of social associations.
If everyone is telling you that John Lennon
died, but you can’t believe it because it
doesn’t match your own perception, you would
gravitate towards people whose alternative
viewpoints overlapped with yours.
This is how echo chambers form, which spread
and strengthen conspiracy theories, often
making them more resilient against outside
logic - as well as more extreme and pernicious.
So, who really did kill President John F Kennedy?
Ask Lee Harvey Oswald, he’d say he didn’t
do it and was instead being framed.
Ask Fidel Castro and he’d tell you that
he and his men were there in Dallas that day,
armed and on a mission to kill Kennedy themselves.
Or there’s the “Umbrella Man”, who claimed
he killed JFK with a modified umbrella.
But ultimately, speculating as to who killed
President Kennedy is pointless: every answer
is right to someone.
SCP-001 was the shot that changed the entire
world.
Since Incident-001-Gamma, nobody has been
able to perceive the world in the exact same
way as someone else does.
If you feel confused, rely on what you know
to be real, what you believe is the truth,
and find comfort in the normalcy of that.
Honestly, it’s all you really have.
Now go check out “SCP-001 - Which is the
Real 001?” and “SCP-001 The Ouroboros
Cycle - The Full Epic Story Explained” for
more on the ever-fascinating mystery that
is SCP-001!